good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's hard
to get people on the internet to agree
about anything like it's hard to get
them to agree about complicated subjects
like how to pay for and deliver health
care and also it's hard to get them to
agree about tiny things like whether to
call a gif a jiff but the one thing
everybody on the internet seems to agree
on at the moment is that the internet
kind of sucks like Samuel Ashworth wrote
of Twitter the thing about Twitter is
that no one who uses it needs an
explanation of why it is the worst it is
an endlessly self-renewing bonfire of
outrage and confusion and I think that's
true not only for Twitter but also for
YouTube and Facebook and reddit and so
on it's hard to get reliable news online
and the news cycle moved so quickly that
it's difficult to follow complicated
stories over time and the architecture
of the social Internet often seems to
lift up the loudest and most divisive
voices over more cautious and nuanced
ones also lots of undeserving creators
and creations reach large audiences and
then the backlash to those creators and
creations is so hyper intense that it
creates a backlash to the backlash and
then a backlash to the backlash to the
backlash ad infinitum first I think it's
worth noting that a lot of this isn't
new like the Internet has always sucked
or at least we've always felt like it
sucked I mean way back in 1995 the very
first joke I made on my very first web
site was that the internet was made out
of narcissism cat pictures and
pornography the more things change but
the point is whatever Golden Age of
Internet discourse people harken back to
is inevitably misremembered there's a
lot I don't like about today's YouTube
but that was also true in 2007 and 2010
in 2012 when the running joke online was
that the only place on the internet
worse than Yahoo Answers was YouTube
comments admittedly it sometimes feels
like YouTube comments never really got
better so much as the rest of the
internet got worse but still we
shouldn't idealize the past there have
always been powerful people who misuse
that power and there have always been
people who feel powerless and vengeful
and use the cloak of anonymity to attack
others but none of that means we should
have to accept an Internet that sucks
look this is a complicated problem and I
am NOT going to solve it in a YouTube
video I do think however that we need to
look at the differences between our
goals as a species and the goals of the
private companies that hosts so much of
our public discourse all right imagine
you work at a zoo and someone comes up
to you and says I'll give you a thousand
dollars every time you get that lion -
roar maybe at first you teach the line
that when it roars it gets extra food
but then
over time you start to notice that the
lion roars whenever it sees something
weird so you start to show it lots of
surprising information you also might
notice that Lions roar when they feel
threatened but they'd learned pretty
quickly that your threats were empty so
you'd have to vary them up you'd have to
find a million different ways to make
the lines feel like their lives were in
danger or their families were about to
be broken up or their territory was
threatened twitter is not structured to
make us better informed or happier it is
structured to keep us on Twitter the
same is true for Facebook and Netflix
and Hulu and YouTube and cable news all
of these companies want as much of our
attention as they can get because that
is how they make money which is what
they exist to do I don't buy the
argument that this makes corporations or
the people who work at them evil but I
do think we need to understand what
corporations want so that we can know
how best to tell them what we want they
want our attention and it is very hard
to turn down the feast that they lay
before us but if we refuse to roar on
cue they will notice and they will
change algorithms and the companies that
control them are big and powerful but in
the end each of us still chooses what we
watch and listen to and read your
attention is powerful and it is yours
Hank I'll see you on Friday